wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
sowohl danke
wir haben so schon viel zu tun es war
ganz sicher die richtige entscheidung
die mit ihm nicht zu vergrößern
das denke ich auch aber wir können
unsere store trotzdem ein bisschen
verändert
denkst du was bestimmtes naja ich finde
die idee mit dem lieferservice immer
noch total gut aber wir sollten nicht
eine privatperson liefern sondern an
institutionen zb eine tafel kindergärten
altenheime du meinst einen kostenlosen
service mit zutaten die übrig bleiben
die lese nicht schlecht oder
wahlzeit was darf es denn sein
ein griechischen salat mit und ein
wasser können wohl keine pommes mal
sehen was vor allen dingen kann ich sie
bald nicht mehr richten
dieser geruch nach fett ist ziemlich
eklig aber ich musste mich auch nicht
beklagen
nach bei uns dürfen sie das ich hoffe
dass ich mal wieder als hart zu arbeiten
kann
sie sind arzt in syrien war ich arzt ich
bin oder logo aber hier habe ich noch
probleme mit ich kann meine tochter
spricht schon viel besser
sie bestimmt besonders stolz auf sie ja
nein
sie machten hier große so ging das tun
töchter söhne aber auch
[Musik]